il
[Musique]
imaginez un endroit sur terre où les
femmes seraient totalement libre plus
libre que les hommes même un lieu où
elle serait le sexe fort avec davantage
de pouvoir et bien cet endroit existe
c'est ici dans la province indienne de
meghalaya
[Musique]
mr
[Applaudissements]
s'il existait un royaume des femmes en
inde sa capitale serait chi lan des
femmes qui occupent l'espace public des
femmes à la tête de commerce des femmes
qui conduisent sans leur mari tout un
contraste avec le reste de l'inde
ici les jeunes filles s'habillent comme
elles le veulent sans crainte d'être
agressé ne va ni gourdins pour
comprendre l'importance des femmes dans
la culture cas ci il faut commencer par
une visite à la maternité
l'infirmière en chef faboulous linden
prend soin de la petite marque de lille
et de sa maman
longuet
quatre mois dans les familles cas ci
c'est la plus jeune fille qui hérite de
la propriété et des biens les enfants
prennent aussi le nom de leur mère les
femmes sont libres de choisir leurs
maris et après le mariage l'homme des
ménages dans sa belle famille les
anthropologues appelle ça un système
matrilinéaire et matri local adéquat
respecte beaucoup d'hommes vivent très
bien avec ce système c'est le cas de
balles à one pinsk m un restaurateur il
a le devoir de donner tous est revenu à
sa femme mais comme il n'est pas marié
dans son cas c'est à sa soeur qui le
verse dans le meghalaya il n'est pas
rare de croiser des hommes en train de
s'occuper des enfants pendant que la
femme travaille c'est tout le contraire
de ce qu'on voit dans le reste de l'inde
en français on dit que c'est le masculin
qui l'emportent
mais dans la lande cassis et le féminin
qui est mise en valeur les éléments de
la nature les plus importants l'air
l'eau le feu la terre sont tous féminins
et quand quelque chose devient utile il
passe du masculin ou féminin
par exemple le mot bois et masculin mais
une fois coupée il est féminin le riz
est masculin mais une fois cuit il est
féminin
mais tout ne va pas bien chez les cas si
beaucoup de garçons décrochent de
l'école et tombe dans l'alcool et la
drogue qui paria a fondé une association
d'hommes qui réclament plus d'égalité
sociale aux gay games and give la guerre
des sexes aura-t-elle lieu au meghalaya
certains couples modernes tente de
partager davantage les responsabilités
pour éviter les conflits
mais beaucoup de femmes ne sont pas
prêtes à abandonner leur statut
c'est le cas de plaie ce midi qui
possède un magasin de vêtements avec ses
deux soeurs
[Musique]